[Musique]
et voilà nous sommes aujourd'hui à
bouzonville audois près de pithiviers
pour parler des préenseignes vous savez
ce sont ces fameux panneaux qui
indiquent la présence d'un bar d'un
restaurant ou encore d'un hôtel dans les
communes de moins de 10000 habitants et
depuis bientôt trois ans un arrêté
ministériel en cause le retrait de ces
panneaux qu'en pensent les
professionnels
bonjour gilbert bienvenue dans c'est
vous qui le dites
de quoi s'agit-il exactement quel est le
problème le problème il est né du
grenelle de l'environnement qui a qui a
voulu se séparer de la pollution
visuelle
il n'ya pas d'équité parce qu'à l'entrée
des grandes villes des villes de plus de
10 mille habitants là tout est autorisé
des six sur sept dès enfin on le voit
bien quand on rentre sur des nationales
et qu'on arrive dans les grandes
agglomérations ccd forêt d'enseignants
alors donc il ya il ya deux poids deux
mesures que qui sont insupportables en
fait
vous connaissez vous des établissements
qui ont été contrôlés oui on en connaît
plusieurs dont un à châteaurenard qui a
perdu énormément de chiffre d'affaires
qui se pose même la question de savoir
s'il allait continuer son activité
et puis un autre à vienne en valent au
début 2016 qui lui a été contrainte d
enlever sous peine d'une amende
journalière par panneaux donc c'était
assez énorme quoi que pensez vous de
cette mesure sur le fait d'enlever de
vouloir enlever les panneaux
publicitaires je trouve que c'est
une façon de
découragés mais restaurateurs tous types
de commerces d'activité dans les petites
campagnes
quand j'ai ouvert mon établissement je
n'ai pas mis de panneau parce que
justement il y avait déjà cette mission
était en place je me suis dit s'il est
ici il faut faire des panneaux pour les
retirer pour convertir comme ça c'est
pas la peine donc j'ai pas muni de
panneaux mais par contre nous afin que
ça me manque
nous sommes 3 2 sur la route un mois à
l'extérieur tu diras l'intérieur du
village on ne voit pas et sans ces
panneaux si on ne prévient pas de
l'automobiliste je perds une partie de
ma clientèle
oui quel est le problème mais non ça
c'est les questions pour gilbert sont en
blanc
quelles sont les conséquences pour vous
pour vous si vous n'avez plus de ballons
pour moi ça m'a pas sa peau map lactée
parce que bon on est à l'hôtel on aider
on est dans les livres on est sur les
tablettes au nez sur les jets et ce
n'est pas tout voir mais je pense quand
même à mes petits collègues de campagne
si vous voulez qui est pour eux un pacte
il est beaucoup beaucoup plus important
est ce que vous avez chiffré imaginer ce
que ça représenterait comme perte de
chiffre d'affaires alors c'est pas
évident de
chiffré cette perte de chiffre
d'affaires mais je pense quand même
qu'elles seraient entre 10 et 15%
moi j'ai eu un cas concret j'ai eues on
ne m'a retiré mes panneaux je ne sais
pas qui je ne fais pas comment je ne
sais pas pourquoi
et environ j'ai perdu on va dire 10 15%
du chiffre d'affaires
vous avez alerté des élus car était
toujours en cours sauf que le préfet de
région a demandé à la dde la direction
départementale des équipements de de
ralentir sur la pénalisation d'essayer
de d'attendre que éventuellement y ait
un changement de cet arrêté
en attendant ça on a
on est à peu près à peu près tranquille
et lake louise pour ce bouquet réduite